and we can bring you more on this
breaking news now on the new GDP figures
showing the UK economy shrinking by 0.2
percent in the last quarter bringing the
country one step closer to a recession
now the chancellor Jeremy Hunt has
spoken and given reaction just moments
ago outside number 11 Downing Street
let's have a listen
hey Chancellor thank you for for talking
to us we've just had the latest data
from the ons uh the economy shrinking by
0.2 percent is it inevitability that
we're now in recession
well the bank of England says that we
are likely to be in recession this is
disappointing but not entirely
unexpected news and what we need to do
now is to present a plan to the country
to tackle the root cause of the issues
we face which is inflation and a plan
that protects the most vulnerable and
that's what I must do next Thursday are
you alarmed by the fact that the UK is
actually of the G7 the only economy
which is shrinking at the moment
well according to the international
monetary fund around a third of the
world's economy is in recession this
year or will be in recession next year
and that is uh principally but not
entirely because of very high Global
Energy prices we are not immune to that
in the UK and what we need is is a plan
that shows how we're going to get
through this difficult period if it is a
recession how we make it shallower and
quicker so that we can protect
businesses who are really struggling as
these figures show but also give
families some hope that we will get
through to the other side with the most
vulnerable People Protected
is there a black hole in the public
finances
what if we are going to bring down debt
over the medium term and give people
confidence that we are paying our way as
a country then yes there is a very
substantial Gap in our national finances
and not just us Germany has announced
that they are controlling their
borrowing Italy has done the same the
United States is raising taxes by 800
billion dollars to bring down inflation
so these are Global factors partly
because of what's happening in Ukraine
partly because of the pandemic that all
of us are having to come to terms with
and the sooner we do that the quicker we
can give families and businesses hope
that there is a way through the very
difficult challenges we face but you
would concede that it is to some extent
a subjective thing whether there's a
black hole or not depends on whether you
want to follow particular rules so it is
up to you as to the size of that hole
and the amount of contraction you need
to impose well there is some Choice over
the rules what I call the fifth school
rules that you choose to follow and
there's also uncertainty in any
projections but there isn't uncertainty
about a basic choice we make as a
country which is whether we're going to
pay our way and if we don't give that
certainty to the world what we'll see is
higher interest rates higher inflation
more instability and more worries for
families and businesses and that's why
it's so important to show the world that
we are a country that pays our way I
just ask because your predecessor quasi
quantang has said that there is no black
hole and the guilt rates and many of the
other metrics which went up a lot during
his time have now come back to where
they were so what's your response to
that but all I would say is that when we
produced a fiscal statement that didn't
show how we were going to bring our
debts down over the medium term the
markets reacted very badly and so we've
learned that you you can't fund either
either spending or borrowing without
showing how you're going to pay for it
and that's what I'll do and this is a
calling for a 17 increase in their in
their wages across the public sector
there's the risk of further strikes in
fact the PCS are talking about it at the
moment are you concerned about this
being a winter of discontent and what's
your response to some of those calls for
higher pay
well nurses are working incredibly hard
as is everyone on the NHS front line
it's an area that I know well and I have
a great deal of sympathy for them and
the reason that they are feeling so
frustrated is because inflation is more
than 10 percent and that is eating away
at everyone's earnings and making
everyone worry about the cost of the
weekly shop and the best thing that I
can do as Chancellor is produce a plan
that brings down inflation brings down
the output pressure on interest rates
but also means that those nurses are
having to pay more for their mortgages
every month so what we need is to put
that plan in place it's not going to be
easy there are going to be some very
difficult choices I've used the word eye
watering before and that's the truth but
we're going to make those choices to
give nurses public sector workers
actually all families and businesses who
are worrying at the moment that
certainty that there's a plan in place
final question is on a story this that
is definitely quite big at the moment
crypto
currencies there is one in the
cryptocurrency exchange which has
effectively collapsed in the US the UK
has previously previously said it wants
to be the global hub for
cryptocurrencies would you reconsider
that given what's happening in that
space at the moment well we want the
city of London and the UK to be a global
hub for innovation in financial services
but we want to do so in a way that makes
sure we don't do things that undermine
stability and of course we will work
very closely with Regulators to make
sure we get that balance right including
all cryptocurrencies
including on cryptocurrencies
Chancellor thank you very much thank you